that's the smash hit that made Jessie J
a worldwide music sensation she also
looked like a million bucks in the music
video so why does her mantra now get
ugly well with Jessie J teamed up with
propel electrolyte water our senior news
editor Jennifer Karros found out so what
is let's get ugly what does that mean to
you
let's get ugly means get out face don't
put on a face to make up space the gym
don't need no need for a snazzy outfit
no I love this outfit but you wouldn't
ever catch me in the gym in this but I
can move in this if you need me to lunge
at any point run out of is that mindset
of like damn you look like dynamite were
those women that are just working out to
look good in that bikini are you
constantly on the workout regime no I
don't work out to look good which is
obviously a bonus I work out to be
healthy from the inside out all right so
when you're just cheating on a day and
you're like screw it I'm just gonna eat
whatever I want
what is your first go-to frozen
chocolate anything deep-fried chocolate
chocolate and chili crisps together is
amazing
[Music]